just when you thought there were enough
Arab and Muslim stereotypes on TV to
fill a lifetime of Homeland episodes the
producer of that show has come up with a
new series it's called tyrant and it
premiered on FX Tuesday night the show
is about a doctor who lives in
California
he's also Arab but you wouldn't be able
to tell since the actor who plays him is
white
anyway after 20 years abroad he returns
to a fictitious yet repressive Arab
country ruled by his dictator dad hmm a
Western educated doctor returning home
to his powerful ruling family where have
I heard that one before he also takes
his cookie cutter all-american family
with him I'm not going you're going and
you may remember what dangers lie ahead
when a brown man takes his family back
home or what happens when pop culture
takes a stab at the Arab Spring and
surprise surprise the tyrant offers up
the same rates of cliches that have
plagued the Middle East far too long
where to even start well you've got the
classic Arab man chillin on a sand dune
shot oppressed masses versus a wealthy
Arab dictator living in an ostentatious
palace public executions and multiple
rape suits carried out by an Arab man
against violent women that Arab man is
the sadistic demands
he seems to be based off of Saddam
Hussein's infamous son or day but you
know some had high hopes for the series
America's Muslim public affairs council
was actually included in the creative
process but that clearly didn't do much
and as love inshallah rightly tweeted
Muslims green-lighting stereotypes gives
producers the ability to say don't
complain
your people were involved but shows
don't always get away with racism after
major backlash ABC family pulled its
controversial pilot Allison Arabia the
show was about an American girl in Saudi
Arabia who gets kidnapped by her
grandfather oh and he just happened to
have the same name as any ma'am
allegedly linked to al-qaeda as the
tyrant I'm guessing by shot of acid rain
will last longer than the show either
way it hasn't won a fan here besides as
Remi cañazo points out if I want to view
racist tropes about Arabs and Muslims I
don't need to watch tyrant I can just
turn on cable news so will you be
watching tyrant tell us why or why not
and don't forget to share and subscribe
to aj+
want more download the AJ plus mobile
app and join the conversation
available in your App Store now